earlier tonight at the white house the
president made his first public comments
since election night
spreading lies about election fraud in
states that haven't been called yet
joining us now is the mooch anthony
scaramucci former white house
communications director under the trump
administration
i hope you don't mind that i call you
that i feel like we have a rapport at
this point we're both tough
i actually think you probably called me
worse on twitter when i was working for
trump so i'm like okay with whatever you
got no
no i i'm teasing you i'm teasing you i
don't personally attack people
because i was like i definitely don't do
that on twitter okay come on i'm just
teasing you
okay so you know what it is it's part of
my last name i have no problem with it
it's all good
so i mean look that was a disaster but i
mean i i watched that whole press
conference it's a disaster but i mean
uh rupert hit him very hard in the new
york post just now and i think the
mandate is probably coming down
from news corp okay enough is enough we
got to pull the uh
the guy off you know sort of a hook
coming in to pull him off that was a
disaster disgrace for the american
people
i'm going to tell you something about
that that i like tonight if you needed
more evidence about
how deranged he is and what a complete
liar and fraud he is
you got it on full display tonight the
only thing i feel bad about
is 50 years from now people will be
studying america and say okay
how did that guy get in there how did
that guy act like that how did that guy
act like that on the way out
but this will be over very shortly he's
going to back down from all that
blustering by monday tuesday of next
week if not by the weekend
anthony you know better than most people
that donald trump has no problem calling
people losers especially people he
doesn't like and i'm pretty sure he
called you that as well
uh after you liked his administration no
fake news on peacock
i'm a low-life loser i want to make sure
everybody knows okay a low-life loser
i i i didn't get i didn't go through all
the insults he threw at you and doing
the research
but how do you think about it
how do you think again these could be
thrown right back at him how do you
think
the president will respond to being
called a loser
if he loses this election or when as you
say he loses this election
that is a absolutely humiliating thing
for him this guy
is going to you ever step on like a diet
coke in you've opened it already it's
empty you step on it and it just
crunches down
that's what's going on in the guy's
personality right now okay this guy
is completely humiliated he's completely
defaced
the worst thing you can do to a
narcissist is exposure and
shame uh mary trump said on twitter a
few minutes ago
this is how a loser loses okay somebody
like george
herbert walker bush al gore secretary
hillary clinton
they lose with class and they lose with
dignity he's been destroyed here in this
poll let's just go over the numbers okay
it's going to be 52-47 the biden
campaign flipped five states
they did something historic with kamala
harris i mean this has been in a major
election my liberal friends are just
upset it didn't happen at 10 59
p.m on election night but just take a
look at what happened the guy got
annihilated he's trying to claim fraud
and it's so
insidiously stupid because it's like
okay well listen the people that are
committing the fraud are voting for
republican congressmen
but they're voting out president trump
okay that was their design of the fraud
i mean it's just ridiculous detective
columbo
would be sending him with a straight
jacket to an insane assignment okay be
like okay
guy enough is enough and the great news
about the twitter feed
you know it's starting to convert itself
into the angry uncle you know that
dysfunctional alcohol that we all have
and we have to sit with it thanksgiving
and sometimes we hide in the attic
it's going from the presidential twitter
fee to the angry uncle twitter feed
over the next three or four days he will
soon be irrelevant
and he will soon be powerless and thank
god for that because the country in the
world was going to be in for a whole lot
of hurt
and pain if he accidentally got
reelected
so anthony you're saying well there's
going to be a lot more pain regardless
he's president until january 20th and we
still have no covert plan as selena and
i have discussed on this show
multiple times but let me ask you this
anthony you say that he knows he's
you know he's going to be irrelevant to
what i'm wondering is does he know he's
going to be irrelevant when he does
these lawsuits and he has a history of
doing frivolous lawsuits even when he
was
before that he was president when he
does stuff like what he does tonight and
says we're going to go to the courts
does he do that out of reflex because he
just doesn't want to lose he has to do
something
or does he think you know what i can
actually win i put three supreme court
justices in there they owe me they're
gonna give me the election what is going
through his mind does he think he can
win
no he knows he's lost the election his
staff has told him that he's lost the
election the campaign is preparing for
the defeat
the court cases that he lost today or
signals of that
my sources are telling me the reason why
this uh
county is delayed in pennsylvania
meaning before they release everything
and sanctify it
and give those electors to the vice
president
is because they want to be triply sure
about every single thing in that process
so that they can defeat president trump
in that potential lawsuit so he knows
uh listen uh people like me know that a
lot of that smoke and bluster is an
act for him uh he's under the gun he's
been painted into the corner he's got
legal issues criminal investigations at
the state and local level
a possible federal criminal
investigation
this guy is in the corner and he is
scratching his head he's trying to
figure out a way to get out
and that sometime in the next 36 to 72
hours he's going to say okay wait a
minute
i got to do this peacefully i got to do
this calmly
because that's my best hope to get a
non-prosecutorial agreement
from somebody like joe biden remember he
doesn't want to pardon he wants a
non-prosecutorial agreement which is
more powerful than a pardon
and he wants to keep himself and his
family out of jail and that's going to
kick in
when all the smoke and bluster and
overcompensation is over
and he's going to say peaceful
transition welcome
joe biden i guess maybe he'll nickname
him awake joe biden
or winner joe biden i don't know i love
the fact that he named joe biden sleepy
and and the guy destroyed him in the
election i mean i'm getting a lot of joy
out of this
there's also that weird thing i'm
getting so much
serena you look like you're getting some
joy
okay i'm sure there's millions of
americans getting and getting joy
um
i mean the fact that my fellow
republicans couldn't admit to you guys
on this network or other networks
how actual crazy he really was they told
bob woodward how crazy it was
they said it in private statements to
each other but you know you had to get
out there and tell the truth
18 months ago i said there's something
wrong with this guy
he's completely nuts i disavow my
support of him
he was at the top of his game top
approvalry everybody looked at me like i
was crazy
oh i said oh that's a kamikaze operation
i said no it isn't this guy's gonna fail
you can't
operate like this and of course the
crisis came that was his iceberg
trump tannic trump noble whatever you
want to call this thing
he's going to the bottom and he deserves
to go to the bottom because he's been a
terrible
president and an even worse person
the only reason why i'm expressing any
joy is because
uh we're in the middle of a pandemic and
i'm the daughter of a scientist
and i really was desperate for a leader
of the country
not not partisan but just a leader of
the country that was going to follow the
science
that's it anthony scaramucci thank you
so much
uh for joining us as always the mooch
always a great conversation